okay it's a 1005 and with that i'll
gavel in the beginning of this work
session of division three
uh today we have two bills uh that we're
going to talk about and um we're going
to
have to assign
committee report writing
uh the first one
is
on sb 412
this was related to
correcting
error in the budgeting process where it
was the intent of the legislature
through the budgeting process to
improve
uh rates
by five percent uh the belief was that
by doing that
uh the uh
nursing homes and
and other uh providers
would be in a better position
to
pay competitive more competitive wages
and therefore uh be able to actually
bring in more
uh of a census
so we we heard that uh i don't recall
anyone having any real issue in last
week's working group on on
sb 412
there was one
small thing
mr lipman from the department uh said
that he thought or intended or desired
that the funds
that we appropriate now would lapse at
the end of the fiscal year
and so
um so i
asked mr ripple to work with ols they
created an amendment
with my name on it although i did
nothing
but
the amendment is the same
in in section one
as section one
with the addition of a sentence
starting on line 13
that says any portion of said
appropriation remaining unspent as of
june 30 2023
shall lapse to the general fund
and
as i said i think it was uh mr lippman's
understanding that it would lapse
the reason this seemed to be worthwhile
was the
language wasn't clear
and then in the spreadsheets that the
department maintains
on one of the comment sections of the
spreadsheet there
it says that there's some line items in
there that are near this that are
non-lapsing
so in order to just keep it from getting
confused
i offer
this amendment uh
one
five
my eye is just blur
one five eight two thank you
um
is there a motion
on
one five eight two and with the motion
we can discuss it so i moved
second second so moved and seconded
so is there any discussion on uh
not not seeing any
um on the amendments i think we can do a
show of hands and then we have to vote
on the final bill right
so i'm going to ask i'm going to make
ask two questions or do you uh
approve otp on this amendment or do you
oppose it so
first raise your hands if you support
it's looking unanimous are you are you
it's a great room
so
um
so you're the official uh substitute
today yeah okay so uh i
as a courtesy i want to just go over
what we just did and give you an
opportunity to
can i ask a question just before you uh
yes it's not that i've had a chance to
read this uh so kevin or mr ripple
i know you took out or you added in the
words of health and human services
that's also to clarify
uh oh is that different i didn't
actually notice that
let me just say on line six it says the
commissioner still transmit
which is fine i just wanna make sure
that i'm clear that's the only other
change
i actually wasn't aware of that change
uh let me just take a quick look at the
original bill okay
so while you're doing that i i'll bring
representative schultz up to speed
um so last week we heard
in our working group of division three
uh house or senate bill 412. uh 412
was intended to be
a correction
to uh some human error that occurred
it's not clear exactly how we could have
avoided there we're still going to
figure that out but but we had intended
to increase by
by five percent the rates that we paid
under medicaid to nursing homes
for whatever reason the intent of the
legislature
came across purposes with other
technical matters and so they weren't
able to to do that
although they recalculate
every quarter the first quarter was
somewhere around 1.2 percent the second
quarter was about three point eight
percent but it was short of the five
percent
and and supposedly in the third quarter
it did get up to five percent but what
this bill is intended to do is to
retroactively clean that up and and make
good on our promises to the community
okay so then we offered an amendment
though because the financial issue is
does the money lapse
or is it able to be carried into the
future fiscal year and we clarified that
what do you have miss ripple yes so
other than the addition of the lapsing
language on 13 and 14 you're right uh
that's
the commissioner of health and human
services is the only thing that's
changed and i think that's because i
think ols did that because there was no
previous reference to the commissioner
of hhs so they just wanted to clarify
good catch by the vice chair
all right so so um we will ignore our
previous vote and uh we're going to show
a raise of hands and support or
opposition to this amendment if you're
in favor you'll raise your hand when i
ask the question then we'll ask a second
question
uh all those in favor of uh amendment
1582 to sb412 please raise your hands
i see unanimous
just for technical are there any opposed
no i don't see any opposed so with that
we've accepted the amendment
um and now uh i think we need a motion
on the underlying bill
uh sb 412 is amended move the bill as
amended moved second second okay moved
and seconded uh is there any further
discussion
motion is ought to pass on senate bill
412 as amended by
amendment number 1582
representative irv yes
representative weiler votes yes
representative bean yes
represent walner
representative nordgren yes
representative schultz yes
chairman edwards yes
7-0
okay very good with that
[Music]
we will recommend to the finance
committee uh that we otpa
uh is there anyone who
[Music]
wants to write the committee report in
favor
because i'm here in a service mode i'm
here to serve you what would you like
okay
uh uh all right i'll write it
um
all right so we're done with that
maybe for my education
422 we're about to debate 422 and 422 is
going to be substantially like hb103
it's going to be identical if if the
amendment process has worked
is it if since the house has already
passed 103
would would
would would we be able to potentially
put this on consent or would we still
have to put it on the regular calendar
it's best to put it on the regular
calendar
all right
all right so so now we'll uh debate it
um
this bill
sb 422
was
very much
like hb 103
both of them
dealt with
creating
an adult
dental benefit in medicaid
that doesn't exist today
adults are able to
get dental care through medicaid if they
are a victim of some sort of trauma and
they need to get their
you know their mouth repaired but for
standard things
such as cleaning
removal of bad teeth uh
the addition of
prosthodontics could be removable
uh there they don't have an entitlement
in general
one of the three mcos
and i can never remember the name
carnitas americas carnitas
anyways they have about 22 do you know
okay it still sounds like something i
get at a mexican buffet
yeah yeah
a-m-e-r-i-h-e-a-l-t-h
yep
okay
that is one of our three mcos they have
about 22 percent of our medicaid market
they are the newest
uh mco in new hampshire
they derive their roots although not no
longer formally associated with the
catholic charities
all the mcos are limited to a profit
margin of 1.5 percent
and if they spend money on adult dental
care which is not covered
then they have to do it out of their
profits
so so this particular mco has been very
good at
at stepping into that void spending
their own profit to provide charitable
care to this population it's about 22
percent
so um
so what 422 did and what 103 did was to
establish the
dental medicaid benefit
there were some distinctions uh
one of the distinctions is was is kind
of non-germane to the main concept they
there's something called a risk corridor
um that uh
that i think health and human services
is looked at
the house did not look at risk corridor
but
there they also found a source of money
for this which was a
a settlement fund from centene
that would has money in
about 21 to 22 million something in that
range
so most of the money
from that centene settlement fund will
end up going to
uh fund the first year or two of this
dental medicaid program with a about 2.4
million 2.1 2.4 somewhere in there for
the risk corridor
that was different
the other difference was
in 103 we amended it
so that
we
asked for a co-pay
by
the
dental beneficiaries
in a way that emulated
the
commercial dental insurance if you have
commercial dental insurance you pay a
co-pay when you go in to use your dental
insurance
so in order to establish the fairness
principle that these patients are being
treated like our taxpayers who are
funding this
we implemented a co-pay that relied on a
waiver that dr finney and the department
has
gotten
okay but you've gotten
good indication that they'll accept it
okay
so so a minor twitch since you last this
committee last saw 103
was it was pointed out to me that
co-pays are generally not required for
people who go in for their cleaning
and in the bill and 103
we did include the cleaning as something
that they would get a copay
what this amendment to 422 and the
amendment that 103 did was it just said
that to be compatible with commercial
insurance there should be no co-pay on
the dental cleanings
the other thing that we did was which
was
different from the senate version on the
said removable prosthodontics
would be
available through this program to
the elderly people in long-term nursing
care facilities or some or on
choices for independents
um and also our developmentally disabled
community
um
the the emotional point
on the of this uh carve out for me is
that
when the united states brings a
reservist or a guardsman onto active
duty to send them in a hostile fire zone
they do a dental readiness check on
their teeth and if they have bad oral
health what they'll do is they'll remove
the bad teeth clean up the gums take
care of the infection and then they'll
send them into the sandbox with no
removable prosthodontics and when they
return from the sandbox they still don't
get removable prosthodontics
so
um so i i think there's another fairness
argument that we bring into this
about um what we what we do for
those on medicaid that isn't being done
for those that we will send to fight for
us so there's a fairness issue there
and this amendment
limits it to dede and the elderly
i think those were the main things the
the risk corridor
getting
a co-pay for cleaning in other words
there won't be one and then maintaining
the
carve out for removable prosthodontics
that's that's everything in
that this bill will do it's meant to
make it equal exactly word for word with
103.
one of the senators asked me in a
hearing to do that to make these two
bills identical
in his mind that was a smart thing to do
in my mind the smart thing to do is to
do what the senator asked me to do
so that's that's why this is identical
to
the version 103.
uh
dr finney do you have a question
please
do you want to speak to the mike and
good morning i'm dr sarah finney i'm the
medicaid dental director
i just wanted to make sure that we also
made it known that folks who are in the
acquired brain disorder
waiver are also included for the
removable prosthodontics
you've read this amendment and you know
that that's in here it is all right
thank you i'm i'm i'm fine with that
all right thank you
uh representative
question
no no question but just a clarification
the
uh
removable risk quarter you referred to
just so that people understand what that
is as a result of the sentence
settlement which is basically a sentence
i understand it miscalculated payment
our payments to
medicare
or from our receipts if you will from
them
and that required us to actually pay
back 2.4 million dollars that's what
that quote risk order calculation is is
related to that 2.4 million dollars is
paying back
cms as a result of that whole settlement
where we were
getting too much money from
so um thank you
maybe amount of sequence here i maybe
should have taken a motion to entertain
uh amendment one three three one
moved is there
uh seconded by representative nordgren
is there uh further discussion i i i
tried to introduce it not
okay
okay is that on camera i'm doing you
wanna i'm doing a great i think
representative nordgren
she said i'm doing a great job
[Laughter]
okay
all right um okay so
with if there's no further discussion
uh
i'm going to ask two questions to show
hands on if you uh favor this amendment
and then a show of hands if you oppose
this amendment
all those in favor raise your hand
for completeness uh
anyone opposed
no show hands so the amendment passes
uh i think at this point we're
ready to consider sb 422
as amended and that we'll take a
recorded vote on that is there
a motion some of
is there a second
seconded by we'll do representative
nordgren
she's she's back to the party we gotta
let her have a couple of drinks
uh
all right
so um
is there any further discussion on sb
seeing none with the clerk
motion is ought to pass
as amended by amendment number one three
representative yes
representative weiler votes yes
representative bean yes
representative walner
represent nordgren yes
representative schultz yes
chairman edwards yes
seven to zero
very good and with that uh we'll
recommend go ahead
i'm happy to write the blurb with your
leg oh thank you
thank you that's good to know uh when
when one might you have your version
when you need it
they say
we shouldn't go home until we get it
done so how about tomorrow if you'll if
you'll do it uh
if you if you'll do it before i boot up
my computer in the morning tomorrow
morning that's good enough fair enough
all right thank you
um
all right
so i think
i just lost my place i think we just
passed we'll recommend to the committee
full committee uh 422 as amended by 1331
and we have the committee report under
control so that closes that uh is there
any other
new business by anyone on the committee
i
i have a question for you
representative schultz do you anticipate
uh
being a transitory visitor here or are
you going to be the new member
it's still tbd okay well you're
obviously welcome here so
i appreciate that and i also appreciate
that you took the time to brief me even
though i was late something
representative rogers would have been
very unhappy about
but i'm not about the explanation about
me being late thank you very much oh
you're very welcome um
any comments from the
crowd
all right all right thank you without
john
you